what i shall present today is
a
completely new version of an old program
which was called geometrica
and the spirit of this new version is
ex
did not change
and it consists of having an
introduction to geometry through
three main aspects the cartesian or
analytic aspect
which is now
very important in mathematica itself
with a concept of regions
the euclidean rich approach
and the
differential geometry
and
what is really new in that version
is
special functions
which help
for making demonstration
and also
functions inside the code which are
interactive
and this is what i shall talk about
to
help
animating a
some scene
there are two
specials have been created one is arc
which gives the element
of an arc
of curve of any curve
and strip which is
an element a patch if you like of a
of a surface which can be expanded at
will
so
in the first example i shall show you
an application of arc to a special
swinger
so the example i shall give you for this
special swing is the following
if you take a parabola
and
a similar parabola which rolls on the
first one
the locus
of the tip of the parable of the moving
parabola describes thank you
describes a so-called sisoid
and i shall show you how to do that
first the parabolized deck is a conic
and it has
c before because it's cartesian conic
and here the equation is y squared equal
to x
and economic is defined by six prime six
coordinates aligned by three coordinates
a point by two or three coordinates and
the quadricel shows that before by ten
coordinates
and
the rolling
of the moving parabola is defined by the
symmetry
of the fixed parabola with respect to
tangent
to a to a moving point on the parabola
so the tangent is defined here with a
special line
and o is the tip of the parabola the
fixed parabola
so to
and this is now the expression
as a
parametric point
and the parametric point
is representation of that parametric
curve but it is different from
mathematica
each coordinate is a pure function
and the the third argument
defines the the range of variation
of the of the parameter
so before doing the the animation
you see that the rolling parabola will
span
a space around the fixed parabola and
that you you have to fix before in order
to have a stable animation
now we can code it's
let's say the manipulate is just a
repetition of
what i did before for a moving
point and the parameter is t here
and
let me see
we can expand with that
it doesn't seem to be easy
okay and now
you see the green parabola is a moving
parabola
and
as it rolls
along the fixed parabola the tip
describes the red curve
which is
the seaside
okay that's fun and we you can
have a
you can have the
swinger in the animation itself
okay let's stop here
and you see that the key function here
was
that function here
arc
which is the arc of the parabola
that i call ci1
which varies and the range of variation
of the parameter goes from pi the origin
to
u which is the
varying parameter
now
shall give something similar for a
surface
and
that surface will be not
defined with a
so-called vivienne window maybe you
don't remember what is the vivienne
window vivienne was a
student of galileo
and
he remains famous in geometry for the
for his window
and the viviennes window is the
intersection of a
cylinder of revolution with a sphere
the cylinder passes through the center
of the sphere and it stuns onto the
sphere
so this is
defined here
and so you can see the the sphere and
the cylinder and the green curve which
is dashed a little
is the vivienne window
now
to form a knot from
from that curve
i define a cylinder
with a function e cylinder here
which has as a base the vivienne window
has four generators parallel to a vector
which which is minus three zero zero
and it gives that
so you have the the knot
here
and the the purpose now is to
reconstruct the knot
uh piece by piece and the piece i shall
choose
is
you see as it is a cylinder there are
segments
the generators are segment and i shall
reconstruct
the knot
with that segments
so in that case the key function here is
strip
and k is the not that i defined before
and
i may have two variables in that case
because in the general case you have two
parameters for a surface
but i just take one fixed so the
generator is fixed
but the one
along the
sphere if you like
varies
so let's see what it does
so you can follow how it is built this
way
okay like that
it's clear
and that is
very
helpful
as soon as soon as you have to
investigate properties of curves or
surfaces which are
not
to trivial i would say
now a second
aspect of interactivity which has been
built up in
in geometry cap plus
is
libraries of various elements and the
various elements are quadrics that i
have quoted at the beginning
of parametric curves because if you want
to to test
things like the curvature to be simple
of the of the curve
uh
sometimes you want to have a sampling of
all the things you can do and there is a
catalogue of parametric curves in
geometrical plus
wool surfaces
and solids so
here
something is very important to notice
you can see that x here
the zero
that says
the command is very simple it's quadric
of x
but x is not an input parameter it is an
output parameter
and this is a bit counterintuitive
uh but nevertheless it is
the way it works and it works well
so now once you have this kind of uh
of catalog
you can select
any
uh
any quadric for in that case
either a paraboloid here or a hyperbolic
paraboloid here and if i put for
instance is here
the
draw 3d
at uh
paint
of
x
oof
sorry
i i shall give you a demonstration for
the following
you you can manipulate all that elements
at will
i have
an example here for the parametric
curves
and here
i took two curves one i call cy so i
guess it is a cycloid
so let me
find the cycloid here
it is here
and i define it
so i have here the parametric
representation
and i shall take another curve that i
call it tr so that must be it trochoid
which is here
and
you see by giving a
local name to
the
generic name
y
of the database
i can manipulate the curves
independently
for rule surfaces it is the same
here it
rule surfaces are
generated by
lines
which follow a certain
variation
here what did i take
i don't
know
yes i took a helicoid
so i'm looking for the helicoid it is
here
and
i can manipulate it now which consists
of making a rotation so by rotating the
helicoid i shall get
a kind of aircraft helix
i'd say it
the parameter there is too
too much but you have the flavor
so far
for the
for the libraries
there is
another kind
of
interactivity built in
geometrical plus which concerns the
intersections
when you have curves which are
complicated
it
the the usual technique you would use
with mathematica would be to to have a
take a solver with an initial value
and once you have the initial value you
you can solve precisely but numerically
the
the two systems of equations the system
of two equations
here
the definition of the
approximate values
is given for the two curves
interactively as i shall show you
and the function is dynamic interactions
intersections excuse me
so i hope
that
you see it pretty well yeah
so the
important function is dynamic
intersections so the first two arguments
are the two curves that you you want to
study
and the third argument
is
the dynamic
result
of the
of the intersection so you will
in that case
it is a list
of the parameters
of each curve so
it will be
the full list will be a list of two
parameters at a time one for the blue
curve and one for the right curve so
let's see how it works so here again
the the output
parameter
is
in the
in the input string here
so this is a bit counter-intuitive but
you will see it you won't get used so
let me do the job
excuse me it's here i take the slider i
have a slider for the
blue curve up
and i stop
near this point
excuse me it's a bit too big
because it's not control of the second
one
i have a second slider for the red curve
okay not
too far
and i press solve
and
i shall reduce it again because you do
not see it
okay you see it now you have here
the parameters
of the two curves parameters are what
they are
but we shall see afterwards and i can
continue for each point
go here
i have to turn
okay
second point
third point don't be afraid it's a
spiral but i don't go to infinity
this one will go this way
okay
solve this third point and i go to the
to the last point
here
okay
now i have the list of all my points
the very first thing to do is to check
that the points you you get
are good
and to do that
you have two ways of checking your
points
by looking at the points on the blue
curve
and looking at the points on the red
curve they should be the same
and to check that
there is a function which is called
pointer which associates a point
bound to one of the curves
so i do that for the two curves
excuse me i have to do that first oh
that's technical don't worry
and i let you judge
that
the results pretty good
okay
so you see that that proves that the
technique is
is reliable
now i can
manipulate
this point here's the manipulation i did
just to give you a flavor of uh
of differential
calculus
what i have done
was
i i drew
here
as a very the friendly serious system to
see the tangent and the normal twitch
curve
okay it does not work for us
strange reason but it's like that
okay sorry i'm sorry but so you see
i finished there unfortunately
on something which did not work as i
expected but you can be convinced
nevertheless that this technique is very
very safe
and
rather easy
to manipulate
and in conclusion i would say that
playing with
this technique
of interactivity
for geometry has opened really new new
realms
and
especially when you want to investigate
complicated structures
and
i think it's also something which could
be generalized i do hear its suggestion
maybe in mathematical
to to have
for the time being
the
dynamic applications mathematica are
outside the code
it would be interesting to see a few
applications inside the code
and
i must finish by
expressing my
my acknowledgements to luke bertole who
suggested
the
syntax
of these functions especially something
which was counter-intuitive for me to
have the output in the in the input
strain
but
it helps very much
thank you